we're gonna have two lectures on
fundraising the this one which is going
to be a high-level overview which I'll
do and then next week my partner Kirsty
will do a deep dive into the mechanics
of fundraising which are really fun so
you wouldn't want to miss that before I
start I will say we have an amazing set
of resources in our library on
fundraising you should look at them
you should read Paul Graham's essays on
fundraising they they have aged really
well and they will help you a lot I
wrote a guide to seed fundraising as
well that I think is pretty useful but
there are lots of other resources videos
from last year's startup school from
2014 how to start a startup one of our
time I'll reference later which will be
massively helpful when you go out and
raise money in it in early rounds and in
later rounds so startups are hard and
fundraising can be one of the hardest
parts even though fun is bright in the
word it's really not that fun
it's a weird marketplace when you get
out there it seems like kind of an open
market but it's not rational it seldom
fair and yeah you will hear of founders
who tell you I have fundraising was easy
I walked out you know I started walking
down sand hill road and people showered
me with cash that's the exception rather
than the rule so while your fundraising
you're going to hear know a lot most of
you you will hear reasons why your
startup will not succeed while your
product is not a good one why the
opportunity you're talking about is not
real sometimes they'll be right - but
you should never believe that because
you will survive the way you were
survived the multiple times you're going
to go fundraise is by being tough and
resilient
and above all by believing no matter
what you hear no matter how many times
you hear no or reasons why your startup
won't succeed you need to believe now I
promise I'd go fast but I'm gonna go so
fast I'm gonna give you a complete
overview of everything you need to know
about fundraising in about a minute or
less and then I'll go deeper after that
and anyone who wants to leave after this
minute because you got everything that
you needed I won't feel bad just walk
out okay so in less than a minute figure
out the story of your startup
this means figure out why you're going
to matter in the future what is it about
your product your opportunity that's
gonna tell a story about the future that
a venture capitalist will care about it
so this this might mean getting product
market fit it might mean growth could
mean a lot of things then find the right
investors do research talk to other
founders this is where organizations
like YC can be a ton of help get
organized you do your homework you
create your spreadsheet and you get a
list of everyone you're going to talk to
and you're going to reach out to or
you're going to get introductions to and
then you begin you will pitch again and
again and again you will find your story
again and again and you will get better
at it as you iterate and eventually
you'll meet the right investors
sometimes the right investors will be
the investor with whom you resonate the
best and who you think is going to be
the best added value sometimes the right
investor be the person who is willing to
write you a check first so then you
agree on a price we'll talk about
negotiations more later and then you get
the money in the bank and lastly you get
back to work that's it simple right I
think that was less than a minute now
you can leave
okay so let's get a little perspective
first why does VC even exist well
there's a market for it right you guys
need the money most of you most of you
want the money but there's sort of
another reason to which is the returns
can be really big it wasn't always that
way
many people tracked the beginning of
Silicon Valley to Bill and Dave start
and kill it packard in on 1957 and they
started with 583 dollars of their own
money and never raised venture it's
possible to do that but it turns out to
do a high-growth startup you usually do
need money in about the same time this
French guy named George Daurio kind of
kicked off the whole thing by investing
$70,000 in this what was to become epic
company Digital Equipment Corporation
and he turned that seventy thousand
dollars into thirty five million dollars
which is you might imagine got some
people interested and that kicked off an
entire industry but why raise money what
do you need it for well you need it to
pay for stuff to hire people to rent
offices you need it to grow right
startup equals growth this Paul Graham
wrote a long time ago and to grow you
almost always need startup capital so
it's possible to bootstrap and some
companies do but it is really hard and
you should keep in mind it's also true
that having money can be a competitive
advantage
so most startups most of the time will
raise money when should you raise money
now the obvious answer right is when you
need it right that's when you're going
to raise money when you need the money
unfortunately it's actually the opposite
that's true
the best time to raise money is when you
don't need it this isn't always possible
but when you don't need money investors
see the big
opportunity so throughout the lifetime
of your startup if you can't arrange to
be in a position where you have lots of
money and lots of prospects the money
will come flowing in if you're
profitable it helps a lot if you're
desperate
well VC's can smell that a mile away how
much should you raise well one rule of
thumb and I'll give you another one in a
second one thought process to go through
is assume when you raise money that this
is the last time you'll ever be able to
raise so raised enough so you won't need
more so you can get to profitability no
obviously this is not always possible it
depends on the kind of startup you have
so you should at least know what you're
going to spend the money on so do some
math figure out what your average
employee is going to cost an engineer
for example might be $15,000 we usually
use a rule of thumb at a seed round of
about 18 months whatever time frame that
you need to where you can raise more
money so you have to hit milestones that
will be persuasive than or you have to
get to profitability and then the number
of folks you're going to hire so how to
waste
well there could be a whole lecture on
this so rather than doing a whole
lecture I'm just gonna make a couple of
points on this first what you know
investors invest in you so ask yourself
if you are an investor would you invest
in you are you formidable enough are you
the kind of person who can take an idea
and turn it into a reality that matters
into a big company right
yeah I know I'm repeating myself but I
got to go into a little more detail and
I'm going to repeat a little bit of what
I said in that very first lecture but
the other thing that investors are going
to invest in is the story of your
startup what product are you building
for what opportunity for what customers
and is this story interesting believable
does it resonate does it tell a future
that they can believe in think about
that it has to tell a future about a a
company that you guys are building that
has hundreds of thousands of employees
like those CEOs you saw sitting up here
at one point they were exactly where you
are with nothing and now they have tens
of millions or more in revenue hundreds
of employees can the investor you're
talking to believe that about what
you're going to build so what components
of the story are there so it has to
represent a large opportunity and by the
way if that's confusing why do you need
a large opportunity Google venture math
and understand what the venture
capitalist cares about what sort of
returns they need to make things
worthwhile is there a compelling product
and traction and is the storyteller
impressive so what if you don't have
these things well you tell a story a
story is more persuasive if you actually
have that product in traction but it
doesn't mean you can't raise money just
with a good story look at magic leap if
you've heard of magic leap they raise
billions on just a story it's a story
that matters everything else is just how
persuasive you are sure if you have
millions of users and growing like crazy
that's pretty persuasive that's the easy
case interestingly the very best
investors want to get you before you
have all that stuff because you're
expensive by then the greatest best
investors are Airbnb before they're ever
B & B before they have traction so
remember to build your story I went
through this earlier spend time on this
build the vertebra to find
the vertebrae of your story the key
points that are the most memorable most
important and build a story a pitch a
sales pitch around that remember
everything you're doing as a founder is
being a salesperson you're selling to
investors here or to yourself to get
used to get to get up in the morning
after you've heard no 25 times in a row
to your partners to your customers what
valuation should you choose so this
again you could do a whole lecture on
it's complicated
what valuation should choose it's
somewhat of a market but it's a very
strange market I would really recommend
you look at the video of Sam Altman
talking to Ron Conway Marc Andreessen
and Parker Conrad from zenefits at the
time rippling now when they talk about
what valuation you should choose around
the 22nd or 23rd minute Parker starts
talking about his experience raising
money it is really dangerous to choose
too high evaluation and in fact it can
kill your fundraising because it's quite
difficult to go to an investor who might
kind of be interested and you say I'm
gonna raise it a 12 million-dollar cap
on my safe and they were like oh I was
going to invest but that's really
expensive and then to go back to them
and say oh actually we're a lot cheaper
you're cheaper you mean you're not as
good now I'm not interested in investing
I have seen companies actually fail
fundraising because they chose too high
a valuation but you don't want to choose
too low evaluation either because you
can overdo dilution we'll talk about
dilution in a second but the most
important thing is to get the money in
the bank and get back to work and that's
why we talk a lot and you'll see it
again and again about not over
optimizing fundraising as I mentioned
kursi is going to go over the mechanics
of raising money in detail later so I'm
going to go very quickly here
about the the mechanics of raising
convertibles or equity very briefly oh
and yes I'll mention icos there are
other ways of raising money nowadays
that have little to do with with equity
and there's also debt of various kinds
but we're gonna talk more about this and
a convertible note is a kind of debt as
well although we don't recommend you use
convertible notes anymore convertibles
are strange it is strange
you go to an investor and say do you
believe in the future of my company
would you like to buy a piece of it and
they say yes I want to buy a piece of
your company and you say ok not really
I'm gonna sell you a promise of a piece
of my company which is what a
convertible is it's not actually equity
in your company it represents equity and
it represents dilution it's just not
actually dilution right at the time the
great thing so like why does this even
exist why do investors agree to this
well because partly because YC demanded
that they agree to it partly because
it's really good for companies it's fast
and simple
the average document here is 3 to 5
pages when you do equity it will be
three or four documents representing
hundreds of pages lots of legalese you
don't need a lawyer for this it's super
cheap it can cost hundreds of dollars or
less you can do it almost automatically
using tools like Clerke but still read
the fine print
you should read every fundraising
document you ever have to deal with
every last word you really need to uh
there are many many stories of
nightmares with people agreeing to
things they didn't know they were
agreeing to equity when you actually
issue new shares to a shareholder is
slow almost always expensive you almost
always need lawyers you're going to be
giving those investors rights that you
don't have to give when you do a
convertible and those rights are
important and important to understand so
usually called preferred provisions so
again read everything okay so this I'm
sure you guys all understand dilution
dilution is dead simple right you're a
shareholder in your company if you sell
20% of your company you now own 20% less
so if you raise a million dollars on a
four million dollar post valuation
post-money valuation you've just sold
20% of your company 1 million over five
20 percent if you owned 50% of your
company everyone with me you've just
sold 10% of that 50 percent 20% times
50% and now you own 40% that's dilution
simple right well convertibles actually
made that complicated to figure out
because you actually haven't sold yet so
there's a there's a representative
dilution but not an actual dilution as
it turns out when you do a pre-money
convertible the actual dilution that
you're selling is difficult to know
because it depends on how much extra
money how much other money you raise
besides on that convertible if you raise
lots of money and lots of different
convertible notes understanding the
actual dilution it's complicated I
actually wrote a tool called angel calc
that helps you figure it out it's it's
more complicated than I'm actually
letting on because how you calculate the
price that you actually get when you
convert includes things you might not
expect like future option pools for pre
money safes we've changed that and now
the standard YC document that Christie
will go into more detail is a post money
safe a post money safe is dead simple
mostly and it's dead simple in that if
you invest a million dollars on that
four million dollar post money safe you
own 25% and you can be pretty sure that
at that moment in time you're really
buying about 25% so it's good for
investors because they understand and
it's equally good
for founder's because you guys
understand you guys have a good feeling
for what your cap table looks like
alright I'm going to go through this
pretty quickly you guys probably know
all this there's angels and VCs angels
are usually wealthy people that invest
their own money they usually invest for
similar reasons to VC's but they also
invest because they're passionate about
things it's a different sort of
conversation when you're talking to
someone who's going to invest their own
money and how they close and and what
their decision process is then a VC
sorry then a VC who is a professional
investing someone else's money limited
partners so they have a very different
approach different process for closing
there's also other ways of raising I'm
not going to spend a lot of time there's
Kickstarter there's angel list there's
we funder there's all sorts of crowd
funding mechanisms out there now that
usually don't play the major role in
your in your fundraising but often will
play an ancillary role that they might
help you fill out around or fill out the
amount of money that you're trying to
raise all right everyone's heard of an
ICO write an initial coin offering I had
a conversation earlier in the class with
Andy Bromberg the president of coin list
which helps companies do I cos the vast
majority of you probably want to do an
IC o---- but shouldn't I seals are
complicated you need a certain need to
be building usually a certain kind of
network for which having a
cryptocurrency is a smart thing to do
you have to know SEC regulations
backwards and forwards it's a moving
target and even though there's big
dollars associated with it you should
approach this whole topic with a lot of
caution and educate yourself a ton so
just again part of the ecosystem usually
we talk in terms of rounds there's a lot
of fuzziness in this now but usually you
might start your company by putting
money on a credit card and then you
might get some friends and family money
usually this is sort of debt you don't
usually give out equity here but
sometimes you
then you raise a seed frown to get seed
round we don't recommend you do equity
in a seed round usually it'll be on some
sort of convertible and then you get
into your equity rounds bigger rounds
usually this is smaller amounts of money
to greater amounts of money and you can
do a Series A ABCD I've seen Series F
and then eventually if things go well
and you don't get acquired which could
be things going well you can do an IPO
all right let's talk a little bit about
meeting investors I know I'm repeating
myself here but it bears repeating if
you want to meet investors do your
homework know what they've invested in
know what the particular person you're
talking about cares about if you don't
you're at a disadvantage immediately or
you're certainly not putting yourself in
the advantageous position that you can
simplify your pitch work on this all the
time you want to capture their attention
in the first minute or two you're
talking to them and I know this is a
hard thing to say but don't be boring I
say it's a hard thing to say because you
guys all probably think you're what
you're working on is the most
fascinating anything in the world but it
might not be fascinating the way you
tell it you might tell it backwards you
might come at it from the wrong way
which like every detail is fascinating
to you but you need to capture someone's
attention you need to build a story
that's compelling from the beginning and
the simplest way to tell your story is
usually the best way to tell it if you
can bring a demo if you can't fake it
bring a prototype it's so fast
especially if you have a software
product it's so fast to build things and
even if you're building hardware bring a
prototype of your hardware Steve Jobs
used to demand prototypes in wood the
first tablet the first iPad was was in
wood anything to get a feel for what
it's going to be also remember you're
trying to convince the investor that you
can actually build what you're talking
about
so coming completely empty-handed well
you better be a really good storyteller
if you come empty-handed often forgotten
is that you should listen you're not
there to monologue you're there to have
a conversation to listen to what they
have to say in terms of feedback it can
be incredibly useful even if they say no
also a good sign that investor meeting
is going well as when they talk at least
as much or more than you do when you're
pitching investors you will suck in the
beginning one of the marks of a
successful fundraiser is they get better
and better every meeting they have so
yes you should practice probably the
first investor meetings you have it's
not necessarily your highest target
investors unless you're positive you
have it nailed but if any of you are
golfers you know that you can hit a lot
of golf swings and never improve unless
you get feedback and take in that
feedback it's the same thing with
pitching pay attention to what happens
pay attention to how interested they are
pay attention to how the meeting went
and what the feedback was and improve
every time and do not leave an investor
meeting without some sort of conclusion
now the best conclusion is a check or an
agreement for a check we have something
called a handshake protocol that you can
you can look up as well getting a
handshake for a deal getting someone to
agree to give you money that's awesome
but if you don't get that try to
understand whether it's a firm no or
whether there's next steps so that you
can work towards getting that for most
species including angels there's a
process most people won't give you money
on the first meeting some will but most
were all right for raising seed
I think decks are not that useful as an
angel investor myself I almost never
even look at the deck I just want to
look at the founder and hear their story
and see how they tell it many of you
won't be comfortable telling it without
a deck and some investors actually want
a deck they're more comfortable too so
you should probably have some short
pitch deck in a guy to see
fund-raising I outlined the 12 items
that are important to have in such a
deck but don't lose sight that don't
create a story around the deck create a
story around your story and your product
in your future and figure out how to
tell it without a deck because if you
can't well well you can right so you're
going to be able to so we're done
negotiations very brief word first I
hope you don't have to
hopefully you'll meet an investor and
say you know you'll tell your story this
is we're building this awesome product
we have this attraction it's great and
we're raising a million and a half
dollars on an 8 million dollar cap and
they say I'm in for $100,000
no negotiation no problem now usually
the most likely thing you might
negotiate around is that cap and
sometimes it's okay to state firmly what
it is and sometimes if it's too high
they might negotiate down but if you're
not sure really what you're raising on
you haven't raised any money on your
just talking to investors it's okay to
start talking to them about what they
think is reasonable and try to try to
zero in on what the right number is but
if you do enter negotiations just a few
things to keep in mind what do I mean by
empathy well understand what they care
about
investors are different each one if
you're talking to an angel they don't
want to seem like an idiot if you're
talking to a venture capitalist they
want to own a certain percentage of your
company so there's this trade-off
between how much money they put in and
how high the valuation is understand the
person you're negotiating with and if
you don't your probability of getting it
right and optimizing your negotiation is
pretty low try to have options if I'm
negotiating with you and I'm an investor
and I'm the only person they're putting
in money I'm in a pretty strong position
Visa vu sometimes you'll be in that
position and that's okay as long as you
get the money this is what they do
they're almost certainly better at you
in negotiation so if you do get into a
negotiation
adhi
negotiation the one thing you have in
your side is you can delay you can say I
don't know I need to talk to my
co-founder or my mother
or someone don't try to match don't go
toe-to-toe with the pros in negotiating
especially with the VCS because that's
what they do and I've said this a few
times read everything okay coming to the
end here what's gonna go wrong
well I've mentioned over optimizing this
merely means that the most important
thing that you guys can do is build
great products that customers love and
that has little to do with fundraising
except as an enabler of that so trying
to get the last dime out of fundraising
is taking away from that and it's
usually counterproductive now there are
fundraising ninjas people who can do
anything and you look at them and say
they may raise at forty million dollar
valuation it was incredible and you know
again it was like people were showering
them with money you should not use them
most of you as your model right figure
out who the right investors are meet
lots of them and then get a deal done
please don't be a bad actor
don't break deals be responsive don't be
a jerk it is a really small community
and that stuff gets around and this
might not be the last startup you do
even if you've raised 90% of what you
want to raise us not likely to be the
last time you're gonna raise oh and when
you get your money and this happened
don't go to Vegas and Gamble it right
think about this is a weird thing for a
second think about what you're asking
investors to do especially when you're
raising a seed round your ask them to
write a check a lot of money to you that
you're gonna have control of that money
based on a promise of something in the
future that's it there's a lot of trust
built in there
which is why by the way you shouldn't
exaggerate or pretend to know things you
don't know cuz who's gonna trust someone
who's not being quite frank I don't get
that feeling for with that kind of you
know here's the money see in a couple of
years this is what they do by the way if
you think you can get away with
something here you usually won't if
there's one thing V sees aren't all
brilliant they're not actually all that
good at being a VC but what they are
good at is sniffing this stuff out so
don't try it's actually not a good way
to go through life anyway but tell it
straight tell your story straight don't
[ __ ] this is a very little win now
there are people we know of them we can
name names who are masters of [ __ ]
right and it seems to work
don't try to be those people and when
you get a no which you will get almost
all of you don't take it personally
they're probably right and anyway all
you're saying is that their vision of
the future is different than your vision
of the future it's really hard to have
an accurate crystal ball I think you'll
all agree with that so don't think it
personally
except maybe internalize that you didn't
do a good enough job and telling your
story of the future take this one in
fundraising is not the goal you go when
you raise two million dollars in your
seed round you'll high-five everyone
it's great and you have gotten to the
starting line
all right you're building a business
you're building a product that people
want you're trying to build something
that's sustainable over the long term
fundraising is just one small step on
the way to that by the way that's
another reason not to be competitive
about it
Dropbox raised their first round at like
a 2 or 3 million dollar valuation and it
worked out okay for drew in team right
they went IPO this year
fundraising is not winning the company
that win that raises the most at the
highest valuation well not necessarily
or even usually be the biggest most
successful company at the end of the day
investors actually do matter now at some
point especially its seed you need the
money but the better you can do it
choosing your investors wisely investors
who will make great connections for you
who will help you build your product and
who won't be a pain later the happier
you'll be
you hear this again and again you'll
hear Ron say it several times if you
look at that video I mentioned the
important thing the most important thing
about fundraising is to get it done let
me get back to work get back to the real
work on the real goal which is building
your great company good luck I'm done
and I'll take some questions so the
question is about if you're an
international entities in London what
advice would I give to fundraise so
that's always a tough one because it
kind of depends and built into that
question where well should I become a
u.s. entity etc most US based
exclusively us-based
venture capitalists will not invest in
an overseas entity or or they'll do it
with a lot of hesitation
so it's certainly we require that
everyone become a Delaware corporation
at YC it's pretty cheap and easy to do
so if you do intend to raise in Silicon
Valley or elsewhere in the States I
strongly recommend you do create a u.s.
entity if you're building your business
in London or in the UK or overseas there
is a venture community there and a lot
of times they'll understand your
business better than a US market so you
have to make that trade-off as you as
you you know figure out what the right
target investors are it's a complex
equation and a little hard to answer
in too much detail and in this in this
context sure yeah the question is look
for investment and then incorporate or
incorporate incorporation like you can
do an incorporation using Atlas if
you're international from stripe it's
sort of instantly so like but the I
think that's the wrong way to think
about it if you're going to fundraise
you should incorporate because a lot of
you will be LLC's or you are not even
LLC yet people won't invest in that
stuff so incorporate so that's not a
barrier so you don't have to say oh yeah
we're doing this more LLC it just
doesn't seem right a corporation is dead
simple now so I would incorporate yes in
the back there so the question is when
is equity preferable to convertible you
know the there are companies that raise
up to thirty million dollars on
convertibles convertibles are fast and
simple so when fast and simple is your
priority convertibles are great from an
investor perspective equity is often
preferable because like I said you're
just buying this promise and you have no
rights and usually when you raise larger
amounts of money
equity works better all around because
there's a little more fiduciary
management you if you raise five to ten
million dollars you tend to form a board
and you have people who have to talk to
about how you're spending that money and
hopefully they're experienced and can
help you through a lot of the issues
that you'll run into because they've
seen it a lot of times so so generally
when you're raising seed you want to go
fast and you're just building and trying
to get product market fit and you don't
have time and you don't want to spend
twenty five thousand dollars with
lawyers convertibles but when you're
raising a huge amount and the company is
getting serious
usually equity is preferable all around
yeah so I'm undecided to talk about
exaggeration do not exaggerate right so
I was trying to understand how do we
draw a line to be not exaggerating but
still shading our vision so it's
actually a good question one of my sites
that don't exaggerate and and the
question is but what about your vision
well a vision my definition is an
exaggeration I wouldn't even look at it
that way
don't exaggerate the facts on the ground
don't try to hide something that's a
problem by either lying about or or
obscuring the data however when you're
telling your story about how you're
gonna take over the world tell your
story take over the world the caveat
there is don't tell something stupid
don't you know though don't tell a story
that's that beggars belief because
remember in the end it has to be
believable
so tell a story that is credible yet
impressive yeah so the question is if
you're putting your own money into a
company what's the right way to do that
so I'm not a lawyer or an accountant so
you might want to if you're here save
that question for Kirstie but generally
I will say that you should just buy
equity in your company and there's a lot
of ways to do that you can you can use
it you can do a convertible you can just
buy the equity you can you probably in
the beginning especially because you
don't need a lawyer to negotiate with
yourself and if you do that's a separate
issue you can probably just buy the
stock in the company at the right price
and just you might want to get a little
legal advice to get that right or at
least do your research
I've seen people do that it works oh how
you do it is you just rate the safe and
give yourself the money right like
that's the thing about this you guys are
managing the money you literally when
you do a safe you rate this thing you
sign it and you give them your bank
account and they way are you the money
right and then you spend it but you
spend it keeping in mind that you are
now a fiduciary for that money you have
responsibilities you're not that's just
not your money it's the company's money
yeah so you said YC invests on a safe
that's true but what's your question
actually in the future our investments
going to be entirely on a post money
safe we just announced our new deal and
that's what we announced $150,000 for 7%
on a post money safe yeah the question
is what's the definition of traction it
indeed for a pre-sales startup well if
no one's using your product you have no
traction the definition of traction is
usage of some kind and it can be any
kind of usage it can be free usage or it
can be paid customers now you might ask
a better question which is what's the
definition of good traction and the
answer is unfortunately is it depends
right usually the one thing to look at
with traction is gross how fast are you
growing because like you know you can go
to a VC and say I have a million dollars
in sales
and that might sound really good a
million dollars in annual recurring
revenue if five years ago you had a
million dollars in annual revenue and
now you still have a million dollars in
revenue they would much rather see
someone with a hundred thousand dollars
in revenue they grew that over the past
month so growth yeah one question at a
time please
so ask the most important one the
question is what are the best practices
for connecting with investors I think
you said other a lot of the things I'm
going to say but I'll say them anyway
so clearly the best way to connect with
an investor is via someone who knows
that investor the absolute ultimate best
way to connect with an investor is via
an investor who invested in your company
who will connect you to another investor
that is the best possible introduction
in fact it's a pretty bad introduction
to have an investor and introduce you to
someone if they passed on your company
think about it it doesn't really scan
very well the other way I'd say is find
other founders who have investors and
get them to introduce you and other than
that yeah you have to cold email but
that's what they do they look for cold
emails and you know that you have to you
have to pound the pavement there's no
way of escaping that yeah
[Music]
so I think the question is how do you
explain the use of funds when you raise
your seed I don't think there's any
formula for that I wouldn't get into the
weeds too much if you're going to raise
a million dollars you say look with a
million dollars we get here we achieve
this milestone we get to this level of
revenue and the way we're going to do
that is by hiring three engineers two
sales persons and you know three support
people that staff is going to cost us
this much money and that's why we're
raising this much money yeah so yeah so
the question is is there an unintended
consequence of the post money safe that
it will force founders to do an equity
round sooner because the definition of a
post money safe is that future equity
feature convertibles also get diluted by
that post money safe because it's post
money and it is what it is so the answer
is no we haven't seen that because we
just launched it so I don't think that's
that likely and here's the reason the
nice thing about a post money safe is
it's clear it's not ambiguous you know
what percentage that was sold so if they
have a percent of the company they have
a percent by the way if you do a post
money safe and
after all if I invest $50,000 at a five
million dollar valuation I have a
percent if later you invest a hundred
thousand and a ten million dollar safe
after me and it's a post money safe you
own one percent clear so I suspect that
your concern will not become reality
yes what sort of financial projections
should you have if you run into an
investor who is asking for five-year
projections at seed you've run into what
we cloaca Lee call a noob they don't
know whether till who who has five your
production is at this point in fact if
you can tell what you're gonna do about
four twelve or eighteen months that's
great when you raise future rounds
series A's and B's you're going to start
to say like okay so you have 12 months
of revenue or two years of revenue
experience what are the next two or
three years look like you'll be wrong
but at least you can do that now you're
just so guaranteed to have error bars
that are 50 or 100 percent why bother so
I would actually deprioritize any
investor who asked for that sort of
revenue projection so the question is
how effective are customer testimonials
well I would generally say not very one
of the most common slides we get rid of
in demo day is our customers love us you
know that's great
but do they pay you if they love you
enough to pay you that's interesting if
they just love you well you know of
course you're gonna find the customers
that say they love you now it is true
that sometimes what you're doing is so
radical or changes their life so much
that that having customers who are
willing to
talk to venture capitalists who serve as
references and venture capitalists less
it's seed more at later ons we'll check
customer references those matter a lot
yes what does that mean dynamic or
static Lee I've never seen this dynamic
thing people should know what they have
like you mean dynamic based on
performance or something oh so you're
sort of vesting into your it's not if
you have vesting schedule that's fine
and you can show them that I don't think
it matters the math is the same in the
end right yes so the question is what
sort of dilution so do you expect at
each stage in the company and there's
just very general rules of thumb for
that we usually say 10% to maybe 20% at
seed if you sell as much as 30% we start
to get a little squirrelly it happens
sometimes 20 25 percent sometimes 30
percent at series a and after that it's
too variable to talk about it depends on
how well the company's going series bees
are usually 20 percent or less but again
it really depends so the question is
what's the best way to research angels
and VCs of course the best ways to get
into YC so you should try because we
have a database there is lots of
information online that you can you can
look up but I would also I think the
very best thing to do is to talk to as
many founders as you can who are
familiar like you can look up what their
portfolio company is and see if you know
anyone in that portfolio company and try
to get connected to someone who has some
knowledge of how that investor was yeah
I don't chain company and how do I
address traditional PCs that are a bit
cautious with the donkey and on the
other hand how do I address dog chain
disease or investors that the currency
and this is a very this is a this is a
an individual question for his company
which is it seems like it's a blockchain
company without crypto and I'm not
really sure I know what that means but
so the question was how do I address
conventional VCS that are afraid of
blockchain and non-conventional
blotching investors who expect him to be
more crypto EE or something and I don't
know you um you have to tell a really
good story to each a lot of conventional
investors just won't go there for good
reason it's there's so much fraud and so
much uncertainty outside of the fraud in
that in the in in that space and the ICO
space especially that a lot of people
run away so I would tend to just stay
with the investors who are familiar with
it and then explain why whatever strange
configuration of your company makes
sense for you the New Deal so the
question is does ycs $150,000 investment
handicap the companies that do YC
because the imputed value of the company
is too low it's not a problem
look the we don't even actually have a
cap on our investment because we we
don't think it's appropriate to think of
it that way we've been investing at this
level for many years now and the vast
majority of companies that go through YC
is seed and the average cap tends to be
over 8 million now so it's clearly not a
handicap the reason you do YC is because
it increases your value and increases
your probability of success and
investors get that so they don't look at
that they look at that as the sort of
the cost of doing business with YC
correct
yes this is gonna be the last question
so hopefully it's a good one I'm not
sure I understand the question is
something to do with how can you square
the fact that we're supposed to be a
billion dollar company yet we don't make
financial projections do I have that
right you shouldn't make long-term
financial projections that are complete
and utter [ __ ] and the vast majority
of you who try to make a long-term
financial projection pre-product or when
you have one or two customers it's a
joke you can't do that and if an
investor asks you to do that they're not
very smart or they're not very good
investors however that doesn't mean you
can't talk about your opportunity you
can't talk about the fact that look this
business opportunity is enormous we have
these customers who have started using
our product in a very fundamental very
deep way and they're gonna be our
customers forever it shows the customer
need and there's many many many
thousands of those customers if I just
get five percent of that customer base
I'll have a hundred million dollars in
revenue and then I'm a billion dollar
company but that's different than making
a financial projection you're not
actually projecting the
framed to get to 5% you're just saying
imagine if we got those customers okay
thanks very much guys we'll see you next
week
[Applause]
you